hey guys how's it going I'm so excited
because today I'm at like a studios and
we're getting a behind-the-scenes 360
tour of their studio to show you guys
how they made their new film
Kubo and the two strings so I am going
to be meeting with one of their
animators right now but they can give
you a little more detail on how they
made this because it is awesome nice to
meet you I'm the animation supervisor
and these are our friends on the
Internet
oh hi everybody now we're gonna take
them on a really fun tour sweet they're
gonna have fun this is a Kubo's village
this is where he spends his days putting
on shows with his magic playing a
shamisen everything is so little and so
cute like hi this is everything is real
- like this look at this like there's so
little like everything looks real but
just super super small this is the
burned version of the village that we
just saw that's right this is my
favorite set in the whole movie maybe of
any film that we've ever done it like so
crazy I mean everything just is it's
burnt to a crisp
and it's the attention to detail is
unbelievable and none of it is burned
it's none that this is actually not
burned yeah nothing was actually burned
it's all and hand carved and painted to
look like it's burned it was really
scary scary you think this is scary
when I take you to meet our giant
skeleton
oh my gosh here's the skeleton this is
our big guy he's so much bigger than I
thought I mean everything else that
we've seen here has been scaled down
significantly oh my gosh so you can get
finite movement with these little dials
of the torso and then the hand shoulder
the arms hand head jaw eyes are all done
by hand by a stop-motion animator well
but in the movie I mean he was moving a
lot and I feel like you guys have like
crazy camera angles - I mean how do you
guys actually shoot this like what do
you film it on well we shoot it on a
Canon 5d Mark 3 and this is a regular
still camera as you know yes and we
shoot Ross and it's attached to a motion
control rig and basically what that does
it allows you to program a dynamic
camera move and it breaks it down frame
by frame
so as you incremental II you know move
the puppet it incrementally moves the
camera so when you're done and you
create life with the kid with the puppet
you've also created life with the camera
there's so much that goes into this and
you guys have to be so detail-oriented
and organized that's why I'm not here
this is so great I love it
so in here we have Kubo's boat boats
boats right he's got two boats here but
in the movies only got one he does well
Kubo conjures up with his magic he
builds this boat out of leaves so they
can cross the lost lake to get to the
next part of the quest and we have
multiple boats because it's in two
different sequences and we have to have
an animator on each boat so it has to be
in two places at the same time so we
build extras
you've got sail and every little tiny
piece like these are all individual to
use yeah each boat has 250,000 laser-cut
leaves and this boat is on a do a pod so
you'll see those two actuators there
those two Pistons that's to work with
the simulation of the water that we do
in visual effects and it will give the
ambient boat movement and it only has
two because it's for the calm water and
then we have another hexapod which is
really comparable to what you saw with
the giant skeleton that we have for the
really choppy water so that's what the
other boat is and this is our sea
creature in the garden of eyes whoa he
is crazy isn't he cool Oh
you're looking at me and you're
controlling it basically what this like
bowling ball contraption yeah it's like
this giant it's a giant trackball it's
like I would say it's it's centipede on
steroids yeah and you know building
something that's big like the skeleton
poses its own problems and you know this
one's underwater so it has to have such
finite movement and you know how the
heck are we going to do that alright
actually control yeah do it are you sure
yeah of course oh and this is our
cemetery it looks just like in the movie
except miniature it's just insane being
able to see this here knowing what I saw
in the movie because I never would have
expected do anything this entire day
that you've showed me ends up being in
the movie so thank you so much for this
tour very well this is so great thanks
for coming and thank you guys so much
for watching I hope that you guys
enjoyed this tour because this is
something that not a lot of people get
the chance to see so when you guys go
see the movie on August 19 you can tell
your friends hey I know how that happens
I'll see you guys later
like you've uh
[Music]